sauce no sauce shush me senior sis
junior okay why is it that so few people
acquire native-like accent when they
speak a foreign language they have
talent you might answer but the reality
is that the people who get a great
accent actually have three simple things
in place interest method and attitude
imagine building your sound patterns in
a foreign language like tying a knot the
more you develop these patterns the
tighter the knot and the more difficult
it is to undo the knot down the line
that's the reason why you have to build
the right phonetic patterns from the
very beginning and the people who
acquire a great accent actually take
interest and start applying this
principle from the very beginning it
does make a huge difference down the
line
[Music]
I want to go to the park I want to go to
the park but it's too late can you tell
if there's a difference in the way I
pronounce the word park well if you see
it from the perspective of pronunciation
that is how we utter the word there is
no difference but if you broaden the
perspective and you take a look at the
entire sentence you will actually figure
out that the tone and the word park is
different in the two sentences and that
is fundamentally the difference between
intonation and pronunciation intonation
is and takes into account how the tone
varies along the entire sentence while
pronunciation focuses on the single
elements and you don't want to focus on
the trees when you look at the forest
you want to see the big picture so the
very first thing that you should do is
to focus on the intonation of a sentence
seeing how the sentence sounds overall
and then you can focus on the single
elements of the sentence itself that's
exactly how kids acquire sound they
focus on the sentences up turd around
them by native speakers and then they
figure out the nitty-gritties about the
language
so now you know that you have to focus
on intonation how do you actually do
that well the very first step in this
direction is extremely simple make sure
that you have a piece of paper and you
have audio in the target language and
you read a text while you listen to it
you just do something extremely simple
you just listen to it and you follow
along maybe with a pencil seeing how the
words evolve while you listen to them
this is really easy to do it's really
effective and it establishes a first
bond between the spoken and the written
language
[Music]
so which tools do you have at your
disposal to make this happen in practice
and the tools are just here I have a
piece of paper and a pencil with me and
all you have to do is actually to follow
along when you listen to the audio and
Mark graphically where the intonation or
the tone goes up or goes down in certain
parts of of the sentence
now welcome first of all to the paper
world there are no distractions here so
that's one of the main benefits you're
not distracted you're completely focused
on the piece of paper while you're
listening to the audio but there are
other cool benefits for example by doing
the simple gesture
I am literally stimulating the motoring
memory my hand my arm and everything is
connected in one piece the action of
seeing the piece of paper hearing the
sound and at the same time marking it
phonetically it's it's huge it's it
makes a huge difference and to top it
all off it's really easy and
straightforward to do because you just
have to use a pencil and it's really
intuitive to follow along and mark the
intonation going up and down at certain
parts of the sentence seesaw seesaw
seesaw sing-along a talking egg they
should put out will to put up okay now
you have analyzed your text you've
listened to it while you were reading it
and you've marked things phonetically
but there's no input without output
there is no hearing without producing so
the next step is actually to speak and
by speaking I mean to read the text out
loud now you can do this in many ways
but there are some ways which are more
efficient than others what you don't
want to do is to just follow along and
try to imitate the text what you want to
do instead is to try to deeply
understand the meaning and the sound and
the relationship between the two of them
and then reproduce it one great way of
doing this is to read the text at a
certain rhythm not too fast not too slow
but a specific rhythm which allows you
to
developed both articulation and
intonation okay so for example let me
take this book and let me open it at a
random page and this is how a person
would read would read normally but the
truth is that I've never wanted him to
kiss me not in the way you're supposed
to want these things I mean he was
gorgeous I was attracted to him if you
want to read this at the rhythm I'm
suggesting you would read it like this
but the truth is that I had never wanted
him to kiss me not in the way you're
supposed to want these things I mean he
was gorgeous I was attracted to him I
thought about him in that way to borrow
a phrase from the middle-school
vernacular but the actual touch the
realized touch he was all wrong
listening while reading reading the text
out loud marking the text these are all
valuable activities but there are many
others you can just listen to the
language in the form of a podcast or the
radio itself or you can watch a YouTube
video or you can watch television with
subtitles movies with subtitles and what
you have to do is to interleave your
activities in order to give novelty and
variety to your phonetic recipe and look
up the word interleaving interleaving is
proven to work as a technique where
you're using multiple angles of attack
to develop a certain skill and obviously
it works in this field as well so make
sure that if you want to develop great
pronunciation you should tackle a number
of different and interesting things
[Music]
sauce smith city near subsist in yer hmm
did you see what I just did with this
device I just recorded my own voice
speaking polish and then I just had the
recording now what can you do with this
recording you can listen to yourself but
you can do something even more
meaningful that is send it to sound for
feedback and that sound one can be a
friend of yours can be a native speaker
someone who speaks the language well and
can give you valuable points on the way
you pronounce and you utter sentences
you speak the language that makes all
the difference
because by doing that knowing that
you're sending this to someone you will
engage in this phonetic activity in a
slightly different way so here you have
it these are seven simple tips that you
can apply to make your accent great but
before I conclude I just wanted to
stress the point that getting a great
native like accent is first and foremost
a matter of psychology your attitude
counts in this regard you will of being
someone else not just being able to do
more that is a crucial point and you
have to keep that in mind any and every
time you tackle phonetics now on a very
final note I have two questions and one
suggestion the two questions go like
this first do you think that having a
great accent matters and the second one
is how do you work on your pronunciation
if you do work on your pronunciation and
the final suggestion is please go to the
description box and click on the link
and you will read a fantastic and very
detailed article about the fantastic and
fascinating a realm of sounds
[Music]
you